The joe rogan experience,
you know,
I would be guy would try
to be nice to everybody,
but I was already on a trigger.
So if something happened,
you know,
where someone did something rude,
I would over escalate almost immediately.
I would be ready to take
them to fucking full on war.
Can I immediately,
can I tell a story which one?
Well,
I don't,
I don't know that we've
ever talked about this,
but we had one kind of
blowout in our life.
And it was you,
I was living with your
girlfriend at the time.
Jennifer.
Jennifer from Staten Island.
We their first names.
Okay.
Right.
Yes.
Big Hair.
Very nice growth.
Great check.
I'll tell the story of how this happened.
Uh,
we,
uh,
we went to,
some,
some club.
Okay.
I don't want to say
we're where she worked,
but we,
we,
uh,
Greg and I were there and um,
she came over to talk to us and said
that she had a room for rent in her
apartment and she needed
to find a roommate.
And then,
uh,
I was like,
I think Greg needs a roommate.
And Greg's looking for a room.
I was trying to get out of my friends,
we're all drunks and I'd quit drinking
and I need to just get the fuck out.
And so,
uh,
she walks away and Greg was like,
Holy Shit,
I'm going to be living with her.
All my God.
Look how fun
can hace is.
I go,
dude,
she's fucking hot.
Right?
And so then a girlfriend
before you started,
before we started dating,
we just met her.
We had just met her.
So,
um,
then,
uh,
I called him the next day.
I go,
dude,
your new apartment is fucking awesome.
And he'd go,
what are you talking about?
I just,
Oh,
what?
Just fuck that girl
and your new apartment.
It's amazing.
Okay.
And you were like,
oh.
So we had like a little thing where we're,
Greg kind of liked this girl first,
sort of,
and I fucked her.
And then he was living
with her and it was,
it was kind of weird.
And,
um,
there was one night where she had,
uh,
told me that you were
talking shit about me.
And,
uh,
it really hurt my feelings because
I couldn't believe that you did it.
You,
she had her period and uh,
you know,
we were like 21 years old,
whatever the fuck it was.
You know,
you say stupid shit back then and
she was like miserable and uh,
she would have bad periods and you
came up to her and you confronted me,
go look,
if you're this miserable,
why don't you just fucking leave him?
You know,
like,
really,
what are you doing here?
This is what she told you.
This is what you told me.
And then she told you,
Greg,
I'm on my period.
That's why I'm miserable.
And I was so upset.
I was like,
wow,
I can't believe he did that.
I mean,
she was hot,
you know,
and you're living with her.
I get all that.
I get all that,
but I couldn't believe that you said
something to her like bad about me,
you know,
because in my eyes,
I'm a very loyal person and
when someone's my friend,
they're my friend and I would
never go to a friend's girl.
But it was a very complicated situation.
You know,
it's not healthy for a heterosexual
guy to be living with a hot girl in con
Ted it at a,
so anyway,
I go on this Gig and the Gig was terrible.
It's a fucking awful gig.
And it was a long drive and
I did not have a good set.
And I was coming back and I
was with her and you know,
she had just told me this thing that
you had did and that was so fucking mad.
I couldn't believe it.
I was so fucking Matt.
And we went and got ice cream and um,
I went to the bathroom and I came back
and I opened my ice cream and Jennifer
was eating hers and my ice cream
bar had a bite taken out of it,
Ben and Jerry's piece pop.
And it was,
Greg had taken a bite out of it.
And so that I've flipped a switch and
I threw the ice cream at your face and
about a hundred.
And uh,
I don't know what,
I don't know what I said.
I don't remember what I said,
but I remember I went into,
I want it to danger zone.
Yeah,
well I wanted to bring it up
cause we never talked about it.
We never did.
And I want to,
because obviously look,
there's always two sides if of
course three sides in this case.
And uh,
I think number one,
I was a brash fucking wise ass pervert,
you know,
with a lot of energy back then.
And so first point I would
say is that with Jennifer,
if I said I can't believe
have living with her,
I think it was probably more of a comic
premise than like a real attraction on
any level.
I think it was like,
yeah,
she was hot but I wouldn't be moving
in with a chick to try to get laid with
her.
Probably more of like,
yeah,
I'm not saying,
I think it was a residual feeling with
you that like I had said that and it was
maybe on your mind that I'm
living with her and you know,
that's a little bit fucking,
I'm pretty open minded dude.
She was living with another guy,
the gay guy and I would
go while he was gagged,
don't give it up.
Don't get the same damn it.
And so,
and the other thing is if I,
and if I,
it's possible I might have
said that thing about,
wait,
let me just say my side of it.
It's possible.
Who knows?
I might've said something about you,
you know,
and again,
I was a fucking loud mouth.
I sat and talked a lot of shit.
I think that,
uh,
in my heart,
you and I were good friends.
We had come up and done
a lot of shit together,
gone through a lot,
support each other a lot.
And I think if I'd said something a,
it's again,
I have no fucking idea.
I don't remember.
You know,
it's so long ago,
the memories aren't real anyway.
They're not,
but it could,
that's why I brought it up in this,
in this arena,
because I feel like,
I don't know if there's humor in it,
but I think that there's
a real moment in it where,
you know,
we were,
I think it fucked me up too,
because first of all,
seeing you get that angry was like,
you know,
scary shit.
And it was,
I,
the irony of you hitting me with
the Ben and Jerry's piece pop,
it was also not completely lost on me
and I,
and I felt like,
you know,
and sadly that was right at a time
when you were moving to New York.
He started going down and work in
danger fields and all that shit.
So it became kind of convenient debt.
We just didn't see each other as much.
We would fucking write together every
day we drive to gigs and then all of a
sudden this kind of
blowout happened and uh,
and you just happen to be moving.
And so we spent a few years of just
being in each other's spheres at all.
And then it was water under
the bridge and we started to,
you know,
hang out and all that stuff.
But I was wanting to talk to you about
it because I felt like whatever your
takeaway was from that experience,
that,
you know,
it was,
it,
if I did say something,
it wasn't from my heart and that
I think it was a loaded situation.
It was a loaded situation.
And there was a few other things that,
wait a minute,
if you are the things that we're
leaning into that confrontation that,
you know,
it wasn't anything bad that you did,
it was sort of an attitude
that you had taken with me.
I don't know.
It was weird.
There was a bit,
there was a resentment thing.
I'm pretty,
uh,
pretty sensitive to it.
Well thinking a lot of it had
to do with living with a girl.
Well I,
part of it too was you and I grew
in different directions as comics.
You,
you were going hardcore,
you were hanging out with the another
Michael and you were real Kinison guy.
And I was starting to move a little
bit more towards not necessarily clever
through a,
yeah.
Clean and clever stage.
And you gave me a really
hard time about it.
You could call me a pussy and you've
got to fucking be real up there.
And it was intimidating
because it was like,
well I'm not worried you
telling me how to do my act,
but you will get really dark
histamine cause I love you.
I just went,
didn't want to see you back off.
You were you when you were at your best,
Greg Fitzsimmons would
have these sets and uh,
you would,
uh,
you would have a bunch of
really well crafted jokes,
you had a bunch of good things and you
have one thing where you just went over
the fucking edge completely.
And the comics would be howling.
And I always knew,
I was like,
if he can harness that and if
he can figure out how to do,
I mean you have a sick
fucking sense of humor.
So when I would see you pull back,
like to do a Letterman said or pull
back to do like any of this stuff,
I'm like,
the only reason that exists is because
there's someone trying to sell Toyota
trucks or tie.
The only reason why censored TV exists.
So this idea that it became clean and
clever and like what is clever about
cutting out the most fun aspects of life
and homogenizing it for so that four
year olds can watch it really is that,
what's clever?
That's clever.
That's not real comedy.
And in my head back then I
was watching you and saying,
well yeah,
you're just going up there and you're
just fucking throwing shit and common
their faces and your healing and your
fucking prancing the stage in a stock and
you're fucking get your
hand over the month.
And I was just like,
you know,
he's killing it.
But like that's like I was coming out of
college as an English major and I want
it to write on,
I've gone into writing.
So to me it was just a different choice.
And it was one that you didn't respect.
No,
it's not that.
you just said it.
You didn't really,
it's not that I didn't
respect the writing.
It's not that I didn't respect that.
The discipline of it.
I know it's,
it's more difficult.
It's a more difficult path.
It was that with you,
I always knew you had a
sick fucking sense of humor,
so I was like,
oh,
it's like going back to Tom O'connor.
Don't pull,
don't pull away from that.
Are you crazy?
That's like what makes you unique.
That's what makes us Howell
in the back of the room.
We're not laughing cause we'd
like you and it's not funny.
It's like you would say some really
dark fucked up shit and they need bill.
I can never that bit.
Yeah,
but they won't use me now.
But Boston comedy won't book me
on the road because of that bit.
I know,
you know.
Good.
I think that there was a part of me that,
I think it in baseball terms,
you are always the guy that was the
grand slam swinger and I was the guy that
just wanted to get a lot of doubles
and singles and so in a sense I think
everybody,
my father used to say,
everybody ends up where
they're really comfortable,
you know?
And in a sense for you,
like you talked about going on stage
when you didn't have the material,
but doing an hour like balls out.
I'm fucking dude.
That wasn't me.
That would've been my
worst fucking nightmare.
To me.
It was like I wanted to
make a living doing this.
I wanted to write,
I want it to go on Letterman.
There was like things I wanted that,
that we're in this strategy.
Not that I like thought about it,
but it was just naturally
where I was going.
Right.
And for you it was like you
want it to fucking explode,
you know,
you want it to be Kinison.
And that was just a
different fucking strategy,
different game plan than I had.
And I think that was a big part of it too.
That was a lot of the tension
underneath the fight that happened.
I,
yeah,
I really resent that.
I,
well,
I did.
I resented that I was feeling like you
were not approving of what I was doing
and you're putting pressure on me not to.
That's hilarious because a,
I've always felt like that it was
always the opposite with people,
that the people that we're dirty,
we're,
especially back then in Boston,
they were the ones who were pressured,
pressured to clean it up.
Yeah.
Oliver Keithley,
that's all he ever,
he used to tell me,
you got to clean it up.
You got to clean that up.
You said 10 fox and T in 10 minutes.
Yeah.
To clean it up.
It was always like,
oh like I'm taking some sort of a
shortcut by doing things and I'm actually
interested in talking about,
so you saying that I think that uh,
that I looked down on you for,
for cleaning your act up or trying
to go the professional route.
It wasn't that,
it was never that it was that I didn't
want you to stop doing the other stuff
cause the darkest shit was the shit
that would make me laugh the most.
And then when you look,
I can't do that anymore.
I'm like,
you're crazy.
That's fucking bits.
Awesome.
I know in some of the
bits I look back I can't,
I'm one of those people
I cannot watch myself.
I've early tapes have you all,
I look at these clever fucking
cute jokes I was doing okay.
I just remembered something he
did that was fucking brilliant.
This is back in the day
where there was like,
maybe it's somebody had
heard the jerky boys,
like maybe like one,
you know,
one,
one of their cds were out and like,
they were like really kind of funny,
recorded phone calls when
they would fuck with people.
Greg did one where he
called him in a car rental
place.
Hey,
you did it with this extreme,
extreme Boston accent for years,
for years after the Bingo.
It sounds fine.
The car's on fire,
the whole car.
You're a fucking human being.